nos preguntan cómo pasa la corriente por
r 1 es decir por esta resistencia cuando
el interruptor está abierto es decir
este interruptor a comparación de la
corriente que pasa por r 1 cuando el
interruptor está cerrado paus el vídeo e
intenta encontrar la respuesta bien
pensemos ahora en los dos escenarios
podemos ver a la corriente que nos
interesa de esta forma podríamos tanto
medirla en este punto como medirla en
este otro primero pensemos en el
escenario donde el interruptor está
abierto la corriente cuando el
interruptor está abierto será igual al
voltaje a través de las resistencias y
serán los 12 volts divididos entre la
resistencia equivalente sin embargo
cuando el interruptor está abierto
tenemos a r1 y r2 en serie por lo tanto
tendremos en el denominador a r uno más
r2 recuerda cuando tienes dos
resistencias en serie
la resistencia equivalente será la suma
de ambas resistencias bastante bien
ahora pensemos en la situación en donde
el interruptor está cerrado
aquí la corriente en este punto del
circuito pasa por r 1 por lo tanto la
corriente cuando el interruptor está
cerrado es de nuevo igual al voltaje que
son 12 volts
es decir el voltaje a través de las
resistencias entre y esta vez cuál será
nuestro denominador que pasa cuando
cerramos el interruptor bueno estas
líneas en donde no observamos
resistencias en nuestro diagrama del
circuito se encuentran libres de
resistencia eléctrica por lo tanto ahora
toda la corriente va a fluir de esta
manera al cerrar el interruptor
esencialmente lo que estamos haciendo es
eliminar r2 del circuito
la corriente pasará por r1 y después
seguirá el camino con menor resistencia
literalmente por lo tanto en esta
situación nuestra corriente serán 12
volts divididos esencialmente entre solo
una resistencia r 1 por lo tanto cuando
cierras el circuito esencialmente lo que
haces es quitar una resistencia y por lo
tanto si quitas una resistencia lo que
haremos será aumentar nuestra corriente
en el circuito podemos escribirlo así la
corriente cuando el interruptor está
abierto será menor que la corriente
cuando el interruptor está cerrado una
vez más porque es cierto esto bueno
observa los denominadores por aquí
cuando el interruptor está abierto
estamos dividiendo entre un número más
grande que cuando el interruptor está
cerrado otra forma de pensarlo es que
cuando el interruptor está abierto
la resistencia r 2 es un factor en el
circuito mientras que cuando el
interruptor está cerrado la resistencia
de 2 no es un factor y por lo tanto
tienes una resistencia menor
lo que significa que tienes una
corriente eléctrica mayor y hemos
terminado nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo